foreign
[Music]
Duncan she's gonna turn a whole family
into millionaires
should I have a fashion line a
foundation
you were credible today thank you I mean
it wasn't even like tennis it was an
entirely different game
hey come hang out with us later let me
come tuck you in no we just keep talking
[Music]
how often does this happen do I have the
same girl not as often as you think we
usually have different types so you're
saying I should be flattered aren't you
everybody's type
which one of us
[Music]
he's not in love with you
what makes you think I want someone to
be in love with me it's nice to see you
lit up about something even if it's my
girlfriend
foreign
's got his coach Tashi Donaldson who
also is his wife I'm playing for both of
us Tashi
I think maybe we're disturbed by the
fact that she could have been in a salon
like me when we were teenagers when we
were teenagers hey I love you
I know
you don't know what tennis is
it's a relationship
we went somewhere really beautiful
together
I'm taking such good care of my little
white boys
I assume you planned this not this part
a lot has happened since My Big Fat
Greek Wedding
my father passed away and His Last Wish
was for us to visit his childhood
Village and reconnect with our Roots so
we're having a reunion we're going to
Greece oh yeah
[Music]
and by Lee I mean the whole family oh
I'm so lucky paging so lucky anybody by
the name of sulaki on his flight
Aristotle what I didn't know you were
gonna be here you're doing here I had an
amazing date
she ghosted him
[Music]
we are related to your Papa's Papa who
was married to my great great Yaya
sister sistelina
come on
my lunch Bula I will be your favorite
I promised my dad I would find his best
friends I know them do they still live
here no how do we find them they will
come for the reunion did they tell you
they're coming no
family sleepover this is one reunion
we'll never forget do you know these men
no I am surprised but I am not surprised
because I'm never surprised
you lost me
[Music]
dreamed about Aristotle last night
how did you know Greek Voodoo bam I
remember your story I really need to
find my dad's friends Angelo and I are
on it okay bye
[Music]
let's do it
I'm calling it you got us back to Greece
you're the head of the family now I
can't really Day drink like this don't
worry a lady is never drunk
pick the one we have for dinner oh thank
you uh I'm a vegetarian
no
[Music]
I've been having it this stranger
streams
Rachel dreams are not reliable
analytical material that's so 20th
century
hi Rachel we're delighted to let you
know that we've had movement on our wait
list
we got a spot at the womb Center
but I haven't told Alvin yet oh why
Rachel
[Music]
he wants a natural child
but hold on you put us on a waitlist to
have a baby in the name no it's not an
egg it's it's an egg
women are reluctant to have children
because it's not made convenient we want
them to pursue their careers and dreams
we can't live in the past I want to have
a child with you I still
really yeah
I'm sure you're all very excited parents
are raving about it it is the ultra
solution
my nephew was born at the womb Center
but he doesn't dream I wouldn't worry
about it
[Music]
I can't do it with a pot in here what
are you talking about it can't see us
I feel Alvey is able to bond with a
child but I'm not
maybe I'm just not ready to be a mother
you know no one's a mother just like
that you become one
we are considering having a home birth
I'm sorry
possible
I won't raise this child without nature
congratulations it's so exciting isn't
it
change in productivity you do have a
baby at the womb center right why
[Music]
your family Dynamics are about to
undergo true none this changes
how can we make sure our baby's not
bored in utero oh yeah we don't want any
bored babies
I was practically the only non-white
person in my entire high school and you
never felt discriminated again I
definitely did but not because I was
Asian because of your inherent bad
personality exactly
an internship that I applied for what
about it it's
New York is overrated it's so gentrified
now how many times have you even been
there are we counting layovers
you always assume the worst about me and
then you end up acting crazy over
nothing I'm not acting crazy so stop
using that word
you're just proving my point
are you two like broken up we're taking
some time off while the cat's away the
mouse will play with himself probably
can I kiss you sorry I'm a little out of
practice
it's clear
[Music]
I'm gonna go to New York listen maybe
you could come with me I thought you
came out here to clear your head I did
and then I met Meredith and I've been
there ever since so when are you gonna
see her I mean I'm here to see Miko
she's an intern here actually I'm the
only intern here
problems with anger depression your
weird fit from a little self-hatred
interesting I know you're going to want
to blame this on society or on your race
or whatever but this really is just
about you this is your rock bottom
what is she doing with that guy you're
being adorable
so we finally get to meet your
mysterious boyfriend
hello Ben hi Praise Jesus maybe just be
honest with them
[Music]
thank you
hey Barbie
can I come to your house tonight sure I
don't have anything big planned just a
giant blowout party with all the Barbies
and planned choreography and a bespoke
song you should stop by so cool
it's the best day ever it is the best
day ever and so is yesterday and so is
tomorrow and every day for now until
forever
you guys ever think about dying
when my heart breaks some things have
been happening that might be related
cold shower falling off my roof and my
heels are on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
what do I have to do you have to go to
the real world
you can go back to your regular life or
you can know the truth about the
universe
choice is now yours the first one the
high heel you have to want to know okay
do it again
[Music]
I'm coming with you okay
wow this is the real world what's going
on why are these men looking at me yeah
they're also staring at me
[Music]
in the real world that's impossible if
this got out this could be an extremely
weird things for our world this would be
catastrophic
we haven't played with Barbies since we
were like five years old
no one rests until this doll is back in
a box
[Music]
humans only have one ending get that
Barbie
ideas live forever
thank you
no I won't let you do just one
appendectomy but I'm a man but not a
doctor can I talk to a doctor you are
talking to a doctor I need a clicky pen
No a sharp thing no there he is Doctor
somebody get security
[Music]
if you're still in doubt I sent you the
royal wedding a simple instructions
don't cause an international incident
how's it going
you've done some pretty stupid things in
your day but this thanks for the cake
[Music]
Henry shoved me an urge I currently
saved
what I need is some good old-fashioned
damaged control
the White House and the palace are going
to release a joint statement
you've got to be choking you can hate
Prince Henry all you want landia is
bigger than yours I want you to know
that you're wearing lifts no not too
sweet home you better act like the
Sunshine's out of his ass and you have a
vitamin D deficiency I think so much is
what you might say to convince the world
about Ashley friends I love hanging out
with this guys
[Music]
you're expecting at my New Year's party
I do something wrong you don't wonder
who you'd be if you were an anonymous
person in the world I have no idea what
you're talking about
[Music]
your majesty it's your Royal Highness
there Alex I miss you
I really
really we are in a hotel crawling with
reporters if anyone sees you leave this
hotel I will brexit your head from your
body
your Royal Highness
forever about him do you love him what
difference
Prince Henry belongs to Britain we can
figure out a way to love each other on
our own terms it's like there's a rope
attached my chest and keeps pulling me
towards you
hopefully we'll get there tonight
without any more scandals
the night is young ma that's what I want
sorry you're not gonna talk to me
you're the daughter of my father's new
wife from afar I couldn't see you
freckles babysit I'm not your sister so
don't call me that he's a complete dick
but is he cute I didn't notice
there's no party without Nick
what if your dad finds out about all
this
what's that it's a knot a nuts a match
for me
forget their stories dude get wasted and
make up with the hottest boy here
I don't know what's happening to me it's
the first time I can't control myself
sure you can resist
[Applause]
you did what you want with the rules man
so the wind is ours
doing
promised that all that was over
why do you always make it so hard for me
to hate you
we gotta do something well
[Applause]
did you like the letters I sent you
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
what about boys at school must be some
handsome ones
[Applause]
[Music]
I never fit in anywhere to Iranian in
America to American and Iran the only
way to survive was to not put my faith
in any of the rules nice cultural
commentary obviously I've had some
issues with culture can you blame me
what's she saying I'm pregnant how can
you be so irresponsible
this is my mom and I's relationship in a
nutshell not really her she's the queen
of stubbornness a trait I'd later go on
to perfect Layla Elena Hi how are you
evidently better than you
time to let go of that anger I'm trying
it's not all my mom's fault I believe in
you but so much easier blaming our
mothers how do you say goodbye in
Persian everybody
[Music]
we were the All-American Family Trust me
on this
[Music]
stop Gary court order for acid seizures
so they're taking my car you and radio
silent on me is that what this is about
my feelings for you were so intense that
I got scared is that true
that's my cousin Gary I swear to God
he's my cousin he's my second cousin
there's something seriously wrong with
you
I'm an Uber driver and I don't have a
car I'm gonna lose my house you think I
chose him
look at this need a car date our sun
this summer and bring him out of his
shell before College in exchange will
give you a Buick Regal date is in quotes
has been the code breaker
he's just been so worried about our son
he's going to Princeton in the fall no
I've heard of it and we tried everything
to bring him out of his shell he doesn't
come out of his room he doesn't talk to
girls and drinks so when you say date
him do you mean date him or date him yes
date him date him hard I'll date his
brains out he volunteers at the animal
shelter hi mind if I touch your wiener
what your dog
how about I give you a ride home
um this isn't the way to my house the
shortcut you're my hostage but you got
down there something for me
this kid is Undateable have a drink
together he'll have a Long Island Iced
Tea
[Music]
it's the worst iced tea I've ever had
one thing about me dance party I don't
know what to do I just know my mom would
have wanted me to save the house I feel
like just nervous why don't you loosen
him up he can do skinny dipping what
about sharks been here jellyfish not the
season it's really the lack of life
partner right now okay I'm just a bit of
a romantic he's actually really sweet
the best part about getting older is not
having to care what people think I'm an
adult now I can make my own decisions
that's good you want to save her save
her
come on you're getting out of here you
don't belong here touch me get away from
her
[Music]
I hope we should go
Maddie you can't outrun the car I can't
lose my license
come with me come to Spain Spain 10 days
all expenses paid get out of town for a
little while
you can think of think about it
why are you smiling I just got some good
news about my trip
you must be crazy if you think that I'm
getting this thing with you behind the
wheel I don't know how to drive It's
gotta be a nightmare
so are you gonna tell me what this
Trip's about this trip is about finding
my mom
she's from Spain over the last two years
I've been doing a lot of research and I
came up with 10 mother candidates
just wondering if you had a daughter
[Music]
I move around a lot
12 different homes in my 18 years in the
system
[Music]
I just got fed up with all the
unanswered questions well happened to
her
that's my family life it's just the only
thing I have reverse
I got a better idea
[Music]
look at your mom's signature that's
Maria askieros what if it said Maria
ostiros and I just found an address
I've died and gone to Venus oh you're
certainly not from this world
[Music]
Zoe Zoe Zoe Zoe
Zoe uh well what's your last name again
Brooks
did I tell you that I got proposed to
the other night on a second date I mean
it's like the second we turned 30
everybody just becomes obsessed with
will you be my maid of honor shut up
I don't know what I do without my best
friend there Chase is gonna be there
it's gonna be fine it'll be the reunion
we all need
I need another drink
I just hope she shows up I think she's
still stuck on her ex Chase from high
school it's sad and I don't think she's
had a relationship since
Zoe are made about her has a ride
I need someone to play my boyfriend at
my best friend's buddy
um you go Hemsworth Zoe's boy oh boy wow
that's a strong grip and jawline
down
thank you
[Applause]
you may be seated
let's go chase
the bike gets so messy I would kill
let's go back to PCA I'm sure we'd all
love to go back I just think about all
the things I dreamed about in high
school and now I'm here and it's like
is this it is this the dream it's really
gross how often you talk about high
school
[Applause]
like sometimes I like to just focus on
your voice
and your words without that
distracting face of yours yeah all right
I have a boyfriend
uh wow that's cool you can't stop
smiling I never met anyone like him do I
know him
no
don't answer that hi Eric who are you
who is that
honey we met online you met on the
internet yeah someday
[Music]
foreign
you are even prettier in person
how old is this guy not college did
twenty twenties okay you should be
careful you don't really know this guy
you can't do that Anna I'm too late he
wants to meet you I want you to meet him
get the hell out of my house Mom get out
now I know that this is hard for you but
we felt like this was the right thing to
do
getting it out in the open
whatever you think you have with Anna
it's over I didn't think she'd go as
crazy as she did I never want to see
that man again
Hey Beth
what's going on you think this is over
this whole messed up thing that you're
doing here I don't want you to get hurt
ladies what's the name the Americas
first prize two tickets to loons best of
luck he's so fun
what do you want to be going to Lord for
anyway I always wanted to go there if
you go out that door don't please bother
coming back miracles happen there he
could speak how are you Chrissy my
mother is dead I'm in a place I swore I
would never come back to I I wouldn't
have recognized you for 40 years what is
that do you I'd say yeah mixed yes yes
great to have her back marvelous bloody
marvelous
congratulations your comment alerts
who's gonna have to do the cooking in
the cleaning not me I can tell you
that's your job what will I do on my own
I'll be back before you know it be weird
[Music]
getting married
welcome to Lourdes here's I am sharing
with you is there only one bed yeah man
I wouldn't trust I am not my mother I
ain't got the truth
[Music]
we're ready I'm not
why did you leave leave I was banished
Eileen
I loved her and you left uncle had you
came home can you ever forgive me
[Music]
welcome to Lords for a miracle Island
you come for the strength to go on when
there is no Miracle you're still alive
not just about and there's always hope
peace that's what I hope for
take a hug me America well I actually
missed you
this is Bella
Bella this is Mr McCandless hello Bella
no she's an experiment good evening her
brain and her body are not quite
synchronized
but she's progressing at an accelerated
piece
[Music]
tell me where did she come from
I sound
or it is a happy tail
[Music]
I am Bella Baxter and there is a world
to enjoy so I can navigate it is the
goal of all to progress grow a woman
plotting her course to Freedom
[Music]
good
oh
[Music]
is she using the leaf to blot her tears
it would be weird to give her tissue
Mira we make children's books maybe it's
better to prepare them life will
inevitably Crush their hopes and dreams
[Music]
you know I'm just wearing my dead
boyfriend's shirt and texting is all
numbers
Rob wanted to make sure you got one of
these I have a phone you have a personal
phone this is a work phone
I miss you so much there's a sneaking
inside of me
do you have a question for me yes Mr do
you really believe in all these things
you sing you obviously know nothing
about it what
[Music]
years since you passed and I still can't
believe it who is sending me these texts
every morning I open my eyes hoping I'll
still see you I must have the dead
boyfriend's number that's super sad I
think they're nice there is nothing
wrong with putting yourself back out
there again you're going there get the D
you make it sound like I have a vitamin
deficiency yeah you kind of do you have
a vitamin D deficiency because when the
sun comes up maybe we just take it a
little slower
I think I might have feelings for
someone I've never met these things
you're receiving are saying something it
might be crazy but love doesn't always
follow the rules
[Music]
I'm wearing it to the Opera tonight
these are from a literal stranger I just
need to put a face to these texts
[Music]
I don't know you I'm not sure oh my God
you should pay yourself a date the
normal way she thinks I am interesting
you need to tell her the truth you
should have said something to her right
away
again
I was looking forward to this I just
felt like I knew you or something do you
think you could fall in love with
someone just through their words I think
you're very cute
the more I get to know her the better I
like her
[Music]
like this don't just don't just happen
love is a plan for each and every one of
us
hi this is Celine Dion sure and I'm
Mariah Carey love comes to those who
believe it and this is really me oh my
gosh hi
[Music]
there's a word in Korean
it means providence
or fate
do you believe in that
that's just something Koreans say to
seduce someone
[Music]
what a good story this is
childhood sweethearts who reconnect 20
years later and realized they were meant
for each other and the story I would be
the evil white American husband standing
in the way of Destiny
shut up there's just this kid in my head
for such a long time I think I just
missed him did he miss you
his song
[Music]
I'm really sure how to feel about it son
and the way you move
makes me feel like
on the way
the guy flew 13 hours to be here I'm not
gonna tell you that you can't see him or
something
[Music]
if two strangers walk by each other in
the street and their clothes
accidentally brushed
that means there have been 8 000 layers
between them I want you to stay
[Music]
[Applause]
here
how long they've been doing that yes
three or four games weird right yeah I
can see I hate it
I'm gonna work for us the family
business construction I'm a scout if you
want me to make a few phone calls there
might be a hole here or there some of
those polls have scholarships
20 years ago
in a rocket that's 40 years ago was this
sticks oh this is Danny nice to meet you
yeah I do not like her don't be mean in
front of her she don't know us yet come
to dinner Sunday 12 o'clock dinner at
12. I love it I'll be there
Danielle's from Forest Hills we worked
on a house over there Guyer Maserati oh
yeah but it was yellow no thanks any
more meatballs oh I'm making some more
oh no no please
two kids on that team everything changes
for him you need to turn down the raw
Rock I'm excited just let it be his
choice
she broke up with me I'm so surprised
your mom's hysterical because she
doesn't like seeing you like this
getting hurt
[Music]
he'll be okay I just gotta get his mind
off it you know get him back on the
court
hey Danny he's not gonna make that team
if he said like this maybe you could go
back out with him like the pine trees
line in the winding road Leo what did
you do you humiliated him I'm trying to
save him from a lifetime of humiliation
[Music]
stupid sometimes
I always try to do what I think is best
for you
feel your lucky sticks have family that
cares that much
we call him sticks I said a long legs
came out of the shoot that way just kept
growing
still growing
really came out of my shoot
foreign
[Music]
10 years ago we created the robots who
now do the tasks Americans once did
Thomas Newton was sentenced to 28 years
after he had an illegal robot double of
himself you hear that robot yes
the seagull is different level I'm glad
you've met a nice young lady I need you
completely focused on getting a
horizontal for me put yourself in deep
program now see you too
Charles guy really wants to bang me so
he'll have to take over tomorrow
just don't want the night to end I feel
the same time
E2 pick up your phone I've never done
this before
the Elena also has a robot double you
were dating a robot all along you two
and I are running away together don't
try to stop us goodbye Elaine goodbye
let's just talk about this
don't do it
childish
this is terrible they've completely
stolen our lives I'm gonna have to get a
real job we hunt them down and we kill
them um two cappuccinos thank you you
guys don't understand they're not going
to be obedient anymore
they're humanizing they're learning to
feel you want to get married immediately
let's go go away to stop our wedding
enjoy ride is over
hey I get to shoot me sorry I couldn't
resist well fine that I'm shooting you
that's not fair
oh my God oh my God it should turn again
it's deep program now she's ferals
what kind of story were you thinking
about how something to prison oh all
right and uh what about
a prison interests you jail
for sure
happy anniversary we're so lucky yeah so
Elliot tells me you're a writer and
you're the last one it should have done
better there's lots of new voices
refugees cancer murder abuse I'm an old
voice you're the best voice maybe if Dad
hadn't just been verbally abusive it
would have been a bestseller don't say
that
your Memoir is great your new book is
great how are you feeling a little off
my game the only reason she makes me a
salad is because she wants me to lose
weight which is passive aggressive I
want you to be healthy it doesn't matter
can you shut up and keep talking Don you
want to intervene here we can do this at
home Michael Milani looks tired
imagine what are you nuts you get BOTOX
well I just get a little bit right here
you know I can still move my eyebrows
watch watch
[Music]
right here
no I don't think I can I can't
if I did say that you took it out of
context are you gonna fight me now
he's been lying to me this whole time I
wasn't lying I was encouraged that's not
true you were lying to be encouraging
you know what as an actor Mark isn't
always great so the times where you
don't think he's good what do you send
him you're so fantastic really
mom you're always expecting the best
from me you're welcome
I needed to do something meaningful what
you do is is kind of meaningful it's a
who no one
this whole world is falling apart and
this is what's consuming you well you're
not helping
I love you
oh okay well never mind
[Music]